we've been walking around the camp just
now and many people that we've spoken to
they're they're not going to change
their plans they plan to make that it's
that same journey again tonight they're
hearing about the numbers of people that
have been killed that's now nine people
that have died nine migrants that died
making making this crossing but they say
it's worth the risk they still do want
to come to England and people have
caught it have come from all over the
world many people from Syria or
Afghanistan and parts of West Africa and
they really say they've come on a
journey where they've risked their lives
already so why not carry on to their
final destination I just spoke to her to
a man who come from Afghanistan and he'd
actually been living in in Britain for a
year he told us before he was deported
back to Italy he said the conditions
where he'd been living in Italy when
anywhere near as good as the conditions
that he'd get in Britain he couldn't
work there are a lot of drug addicts
there and he really felt that it was
worth risking his life again making that
journey again to get to Britain just
because they would have such a better
quality of life living in England and
you can see that actually the camps here
are quite well laid out I mean they they
are very basic but people living here
have erected their own houses there's
little shops there's even a church here
so people are sort of used to making
that journey every single night where
they're going to attempt to get on board
the trucks they're going to attempt to
to get to England and it's such a
problem you'll see behind us as well
there is quite a big fence that block
people from walking up on the motorway
which I guess French authorities will be
hoping is at least a deterrence have
them have people wandering in the rows
but it's certainly people are hearing in
this camp about the deaths but it isn't
putting people off they're still
determined to to come to England